Growing up in a family with three generations,...
...I've always been very close to my grandfather.
When I was four years old, my grandfather and I were walking in a park in Japan...
...when he suddenly got lost.
It was one of the scariest moments I've ever experienced in my life,...
...and it was also the first instance that informed us...
...that my grandfather had Alzheimer's disease.
Over the past 12 years, his condition got worse and worse,...
...and his wandering in particular caused my family a lot of stress.
Then one night, about two years ago,...
...I was looking after my grandfather and I saw him stepping out of the bed.
The moment his foot landed on the floor,...
...I thought, "Why don't I put a pressure sensor on the heel of his foot?"
Once he stepped onto the floor and out of the bed,...
...the pressure sensor would detect an increase in pressure caused by body weight,...
...and then wirelessly send an audible alert to the caregiver's smartphone.
That way, my aunt could sleep much better at night...
...without having to worry about my grandfather's wandering.
So now I'd like to perform a demonstration of the sock.
So, once the patient steps onto the floor,...
...an alert is sent to the caregiver's smartphone.
One thing I'll never forget...
...is when my device first caught my grandfather's wandering out of bed at night.
At that moment, I was really struck by the power of technology...
...to change lives for the better.
People living happily and healthily: that's the world that I imagine.
Thank you very much.